hey everyone thank you so much for
coming to designing for a neuro-diverse
world we're so thrilled to have you my
name is Christina couch I'm the
administrator of the MIT communications
forum which puts on events like this
throughout both fall and spring
semesters we're very very excited today
and in particular we want to kick it
right off by thanking our sponsors
specifically radius at MIT has been a
great partner for many of our events as
well as the mind hand heart Innovation
Fund they are really the two entities
that make events like this possible so
thank you so much to them so we're very
excited about our panelists today I'm
just going to go down and introduce
everybody and then we'll kick off the
event our moderator for this evening
first of all is dr. Rosalind Picard
dr. Picard is the founder and director
of the effective computing Research
Group at MIT
she's also co-director of the media labs
advancing well-being initiative and
faculty chair of mi t--'s mind hand
heart initiative she co-founded the
technology companies and Pataca
Incorporated which creates wearable
sensors and analytics to improve health
and affect Eva incorporated which
delivers technologies to measure and
communicate emotion coming up next is
dr. Ed's seong said Ned Sahin who I am
butchering his name unfortunately dr.
Sahin is a neuroscientist and CEO of
brain power LLC a company that makes
wearable artificial intelligence systems
to aid people with brain related
challenges he is the founding member of
the empowered brain Institute and a
principal investigator for seven
government contracts for wearable brain
monitoring systems to assess and improve
cognitive States his academic work has
been published in prestigious journals
such as science and nature neuroscience
and brain power he focuses on building
augmented reality systems that teach
skills for social interaction language
behavior and job skills next on the list
is Rafiq Abdul Suber I'm pronouncing
that I was president and CEO of the
empowered brain Institute which is a
non-profit disability advocacy and
support organization for individuals
with autism and their families
Rafik is also a board member for brain
power LLC
and founder of the education technology
firm edgewise education coming up next
we have Finn Gardner is a disability
advocate and policy analyst specializing
in intersectional disability justice and
acceptance accessible technology
he's a research assistant at the Lurie
Institute for disability policy at
Brandeis University where his work
focuses on public policies for autistic
individuals
mr. Gardner also works with the autistic
Self Advocacy Network and speaks
frequently about his own experiences
with autism
dr. Karthik done a car is coming up next
he's a computer scientist in the fields
of machine learning natural language
processing and human-computer
interaction he is also a founder of
c-3po or the Cambridge computational
clinical psychology org a group of
interdisciplinary researchers focused on
bringing together machine learning
casual interface and clinical psychology
dr. jenna car received an Asperger's
diagnosis when he was a graduate student
at MIT for this event we also want to
mention that we have live captioning
available so there is the website if
anybody would like those services once
again we'd like to thank mind hand heart
and radius at MIT if you have any
interest in events like this please come
after the event and sign up for our
mailing list now there's a pen you can
do that with thank you so much to our
panelists once again everybody is going
to say a little bit about themselves and
then we'll kick off the moderated
session and thank you all for being here
so we're gonna start with each of us
saying a little bit about what we're
currently thinking about and working on
and actually I'm gonna start on the end
with Karthik I'm a research scientist at
the Media Lab focusing on statistical
machine learning natural language
processing and human-computer
interaction I actually graduated from
Ross's group just last year so I'm kind
of new and what I do in my current after
I have been focusing recently on the use
of machine learning in the criminal
justice system where people all across
the u.s. many states are adopting
these risk assessment algorithms to
inform judges and various decisions that
people take as folks move through the
criminal justice system
I'm deeply very troubled by this and I
don't think we should be substituting
placing our humanity in front of us when
we deal with other human beings with
something that just spits out a risk or
especially doing things like predicting
how risky somebody might be in the
future as if they're metallic objects
with a defined mass which can never
change and I'm super excited to
collaborate with a bunch of people at
the Media Lab so that's what I do all
right
I'm actually wearing several hats at the
moment I am currently working on several
public policy briefs and projects
recently I wrapped up a project about
making like behavioral interventions
that are actually empathic and actually
have an effect on people with
disabilities except for example autistic
people or people with ADHD who maybe
experience saying may be experiencing
meltdowns or shutdowns I also worked on
a policy brief about telehealth and how
these technologies can be used for
people with all kinds of disabilities
and some of the intersections between
accessibility and state law and policy
and other factors like affordability and
other related issues I'm also working on
like in my spare time I'm also working
like I also do a lot of research around
a inclusive technology and making it
more accessible making it more inclusive
for people with disabilities or people
in different countries I believe very
strongly in the idea that technology is
something
that should be available to everyone I
don't think that it is a good idea to
sort of associate to sort of have this
idea in your head of the average
technology user who has generally a
white cisgender American man without a
disability that you can't have this
ideal user in mind you have to
understand that there are all kinds of
users that will be interacting with your
product and my research interests and my
research interest whether formal or
informal are informed by my own
experiences as an autistic person I was
diagnosed when I was very young about
three and so I've always known about it
and I've always had this awareness of
being different of being excluded of
being sort of pushed to the margins for
various reasons you know awesome awesome
I'm black and I have experienced racism
and ableism all other and all several
other kinds of marginalization so I'm
acutely aware of how technology how
policy can either include or exclude
people and so my work and my work in
Toto is sort of devoted to dismantling
this idea that policy or technology has
to conform has to conform to this idea
of the sort of Platonic ideal of the
ideal citizen or ideal user I know they
seem sort of like disparate disciplines
but from either reintegrated that's me
good evening everyone you can respond
it's okay good evening everyone evening
my background is in education and I
bring that lens to the work of the
Institute we when I think about
designing for a neuro-diverse world two
words two ideas obviously stick out and
that's the design element and then you
know a diverse and I think what I think
about design I think about experience I
think about what is what is the
experience of at the individual level
and at the collective level and and how
do those experiences in a
and I feel like for our work at the
Institute so the Institute came out of
rain power to complement the work that
brain power is doing and so they the
extent that brain power which Ned will
speak more about at a moment focuses on
empowering the individual to have acts
full access to technology into the world
and be in this set essentially realize
their full potential
we focus more on the the community or a
collective experience and what what we
need to do what we need to learn and and
how we need to set up structures in
society so that we're doing our part
right and so that's the work that we
focus on we we work with Avery Norman
then at the at the Media Lab I think
he's in the sculpting evolution group to
to craft these of environments that are
truly neuro
inclusive there's a there's a common
notion and education called Universal
Design for Learning and it came from
Universal Design which is which is a
concept in architecture and the basic
premise of it is you know if you're
designing a doorway for structure for a
building you want to think about all the
ways people who will access that that
doorway right so like people obviously
will walk through it people you know but
what about people who are disabled who
don't have able you know I don't have
legs in a wheelchair maybe they want to
maybe want to ride a skateboard through
it and and sort of you know embedding
that in the design right from the
beginning as opposed to adding a ramp
later right or door and so and you see a
lot of examples of that in architecture
so it comes from that concept but it
essentially it may be it was established
to address physical handicaps and it
doesn't do as good of a job in my
opinion of addressing
neural atypical learning right so so
what we've tried to do is take take
those ideas take ideas from the clinical
world take ideas from the environmental
world is this movement around said
having a sensory friendly experience
right we the more we learn about the
language of autism and other narrow
atypical profiles we you know the you
see places in society that are taking
steps to accommodate this this
alternative experience and so we we sort
of take the learning from all those
places and and and try to create an
experience that where you you where
everyone has a certain level of access
to it but you don't have to when you
enter it you don't have to be identified
as oh you have this issue and so this is
for you and this is how you're going to
engage but it's embedded in your entire
experience and that's been our challenge
and that's what we've been working on
and I'm constantly reminded of how
important it is to get it right
we one of the things we also host our
workshops for children who are really
typical and we will get requests from
families who you know from one family
particularly that sticks out of my mind
there was a there was a woman was
bringing her daughter who was on the
spectrum and she said you know we're
really excited about this opportunity we
really we rarely see workshops like this
initiatives like this that that that
really want to include us and and are
catered to unique needs but my daughter
doesn't agree with her diagnosis and if
there's anything about this experience
that labels her or directs attention to
her difference
she'll be horrified right and so and so
that's our challenge right so and and
and I think if you can get it right if
you can create a truly neuro inclusive
environment there won't be any need to
label one child as this way you know
it's sort of embedded in the experience
everybody gets this individualized
personal experience where you meet them
where they are and that and you sort of
engage that zone of proximal development
which is
term from education and and and and they
can which accelerates their capacity to
learn and I think that's what we think
about that's what we're trying to
perfect we hope that we'll be able to
distill what we learn from these
experiments and in language that is
useful for engineers and policy makers
and anyone who's interested in creating
truly narrow inclusive environments my
passion and my company's mission is to
empower people with invisible brain
differences and brain challenges and we
do that at brain power the name of the
company at many levels and meta levels
so for instance we hire a lot of people
on the autism spectrum and people with
other diagnoses and maybe undiagnosed
differences we make a product that
targets the autism community and another
product that targets the people with
brain injuries and some adjacent
conditions and we run internships for
people who have a passion to helping the
community have a sibling in the
community are and therefore our member
of the community and/or are on on one
spectrum or another and we model and
live with all day every day these real
challenges this is not something that's
in spherical chamber in a vacuum in a
lab this is regular daily life for us as
a team and for the people who are
serving so backing up my background my
PhD all my Master's was from MIT and
then my father was an MIT man through
and through and so I had to ask his
permission to go get my PhD at Harvard
safety school and then postdoc out in
California which was not Boston that was
the main requirement for my postdoc so I
went to the Salk Institute but all of
that academic work and yeah papers and
good journals I still had this need to
what I say now is to make tools for
Tuesday what are we going to do to meet
the actual needs in a messy reality of
family life and school life and so we
make practical tools and wanted to make
them high-tech and nerdy and based on
the newest in neuroscience and just a
quick thing so you know some of the the
challenges involved so with the wearable
computer eye wearing our software can
first of all find where faces are and
get called to their attention because
they turn into cool cartoons and when I
look at the cartoons I started figuring
out what the facial emotions are thanks
to thanks to roster card software and if
I decipher it correctly I get points
it's game of five compete and by the way
if I'm starting to get stressed we have
a stress measuring algorithm and start
rocking it'll pick that up and give me
my favorite music which can auto adapt
and so forth so it's a multi wearable
environment multi-purpose and but not to
be stapled to the person's head this is
something that you can do as a practice
ten minutes twenty minutes a day and
then you might think well you know can
people with autism wear a thing on their
head well 200 say they can because we've
been testing this and our seven
published papers say they can would they
work in school yeah publish papers would
would they break it it's not easy to
break and so forth so we've been testing
out the hypotheses which comes down to a
key thing we've immersed ourselves in
the community when I say the community
what's the community because we're the
stakeholders is it people with autism
well that's just part parents have one
set of needs teachers have another set
of needs their boss is the principal of
the school has a very different set of
needs
agencies have different sets of
pressures I'll go on more later don't
want to keep going too far here but main
point is that all day every day
immersed in life with differently abled
Minds and it's fascinating exciting
challenging for everyone and a really
rich environment out of which it's quite
probable products will come that were
surprising based on what we first would
have thought of and likely to be
compatible with more sets of minds and
brains because we live in every day I'm
inspired I I'll say just a little bit
about what I do and then most the time
I'm gonna get you guys talking and then
we're gonna bring the whole audience and
in a little while - I love working with
different kinds of minds I'm currently
teaching the course I started MIT years
ago on autism theory and technology but
we wonder if the word autism should not
even be in the title if it should just
be about helping different kinds of
minds to succeed but every really cool
thing my students and my research has
become focused on recently really has
sprung out of working with people on the
autism spectrum
we started with trying to understand
emotion to build computers that were
more emotionally intelligent and started
adapting that to help people understand
emotion better while trying to measure
stress better we accidentally discovered
that we were picking up seizures lo and
behold so I learned about epilepsy and a
whole bunch of other neurological
differences in our brains and through
that started commercializing wearables
that could go out to not only monitor
stress but also help detect seizures in
fact our first one from the Media Lab I
have to brag for a moment just became
FDA certified in the past few weeks so
crazy things that your students build
that accidentally discover stuff can
actually wind up becoming medically
useful now we're back to emotion you
mentioned some of the software our team
has built commercialized through a
Factiva but at the Media Lab we're
really focused on understanding how
emotion and its
germán its communication can enrich
lives all lives and help us all flourish
better and I was thinking Finny's I was
listening to you there's so much talk
about identity I'm really fascinated by
this these days you know identifying you
know I'm identifying up here with being
quite different because I'm not wearing
the dark blue jacket and the dark shirt
but also because I'm female right but
I've never felt like I fit in to
whatever the female role was as somebody
who was attracted to engineering because
when I went to school they said I needed
to make sure I took typing because I
could become a secretary if I ever chose
to work or a teacher they never really
indicated I could be an inventor of cool
technology so I never really fit with
what the expectations were with
identities I've always kind of resisted
those but with emotions as we get into
the diversity of uses I'm a completely
different person when I'm using this and
I'm stressed out or when I'm tired or
when I'm really focused and I'm not sure
I'm a completely different person when
I'm white or black using it so while
that is important for some things when
it comes to designing technology I think
we need to think not just about all of
these identity things but also all the
different things a single person can be
when they're they're using it as well so
I'll bring that perspective into so
today's isn't just about all those
labels although those are important but
also all the ways we can be diverse
within one person fully agree I though I
talked about separate in identities I do
have a very strong individual identity
identify with my own accomplishments
identify with my own ideas identify with
my own opinions my politics my
philosophy my creativity my intelligence
these other internal factors that are
while they're not completely completely
separate from these externalized
identities that I have they are you know
vastly important with regard to how
people how this relates to technology or
how this relates to how people move
through the world when I was growing up
I was
often underestimated because I was
diagnosed very early I had a doctor tell
my parents that I would apparently never
learn so that was that was clearly not
true everyone can learn and there is
this idea that if you are on the
spectrum you can't have emotions
you can't interact with the world you
can't learn you can't pick things up and
I mean of course that's patently untrue
and I also think that technology can be
used to sort of facilitate interacting
with the world and adapting one's
experiences I also think that technology
shouldn't be used to fix people but help
them navigate through the world that
isn't necessarily created for them for
example in my case I found that for one
of the things that I struggled with was
being able to reach out and make
friendships that worked for me that
matched my interests that matched my
sort of match my personality that sort
of matched the way that I perceived the
world and the people in it and honestly
one of the things that helped me was
actually going online and I actually
found that interacting with people
through text was an easier way of
picking up on social cues and I think
that may also apply in the educational
sphere or other places where autistic
people are other people who tend to
interact more easily with text can have
social interactions and other and other
difficulties interpreted through text
through explanatory things sort of like
tooltips that pop up for example you can
do social training that uses textual
explanations or for example like glasses
you could have something pop up it says
happy or sad or depressed or angry sort
of this concurrent the sort of sort of
concurrent processing that allows you to
understand and interpret the world as
you move through it and I also think
that one of the things that I personally
find really it
citing and sort of revelatory is the
expanded use of assistive technology for
communication like assisted AAC
assistive and augmentative communication
like proloquo2go on the ipad and similar
apps on Android although I think but I
believe most of them are on iOS because
before a lot of non-speaking autistic
people were constantly underestimated
they were treated as though they were
unintelligent that they couldn't
communicate that they couldn't interact
with the world I was personally a late
talker and I feel as though I would have
I would not have been interpreted as an
intellectually disabled if I did not I
mean if I had had the technology that's
currently available now unfortunately I
was two years old in 1988 so that was a
you know figment of people's
imaginations back then so I think that
is sort of leveraging the things that
technology can do can help raise
expectations of people with disabilities
because I think that underestimation is
just toxic I think that it is one of the
most deleterious things that you can go
through as a person with a disability
I'd love to hear each of you say a
little bit more about either and you can
kind of pick your diverse question here
the neurodiversity thing you're most
excited about and design or what is not
not neurotypical this is a question from
the communication forum it's not pick
one of those two will allow a little
freedom here and I'll go with whoever
then just spoke so I don't know okay
okay we'll go Ned and then Karthik we
joke a little bit around the company
because we're unclear if anyone in the
company is neurotypical and of course it
raises the question I mean it's a little
bit trite to say hey we're all on the
spectrum we're all not neurotypical
that's that's neat and that's that's
important as a perspective to understand
that there are many spectra and we fall
we do in a Gaussian or non Gaussian
distribution it's also good to
understand that like in a Gaussian
distribution many people fall into a
fairly narrow space where they're
predictable that is a real thing
it's again it makes you feel good to say
hey we're all on this big spectrum but
in fact ignoring that would be a problem
because there's a lot of blindness that
comes with this of us you know
interesting term to use sorry but in
terms of who your customers are and what
the customers are saying to you because
if you say well we put out a product it
was good enough for many people many
people are saying this is fine well many
describes that central tendency of a
distribution so you may not get the
feedback and you may be unable to bring
it back in if you don't understand that
in fact many people do fall into a
heteronormative cisgender bla bla bla
and if you just cater to them you may
not notice you're missing say 20% and
hey 80% is good enough fine but that's
20% that's one out of five that you're
missing so it's important to understand
that there are people at edges of a
distribution but then they're all over
those edges of distributions so there
isn't a stereotype to people who are not
stereotypical and so it's harder to
reach them it's harder to meet them it's
particularly harder to sit in a room of
say four white haired men and
pontificate about what it's like to meet
them and meet their needs so it's not
just for titular purposes or to look
good on on Facebook that you have a
diverse team it is absolutely necessary
on top of that the world is now
interconnected and ratings come to you
from all parts and people who are most
offended will be most vocal so that 20%
even if it's 2% will now give a
different kind of feedback and it'll hit
you when it's probably too late all the
best to bake it in from the beginning so
someone answered a different question
than you asked because I don't know what
is none
typical it depends on the domain it
depends on time people change over time
if some of the non neurotypical ax t is
a developmental difference i will get
there but i will get there slower than
the large central tendency of the cohort
then my neuro divergence will change
over time some point I might from
external purposes catch up oh and then
everything's fine right but no I don't
have the same shared experience as
others in that group and so I won't
connect with and identify with the
product the service the philosophy the
messaging there's more but there's more
panelists I actually don't know what it
means to be neurotypical it's kind of
like a machine learning problem where
you ask what the objective function and
whose setting that is and that kind of
is decided by a community of people and
everybody basically just follows what's
the dog I will say though that when I
hear things about getting a label or
getting a diagnosis it seems to me just
by personal experience that what matters
the most is the first principle of what
is it that we truly value for instance
when I took the autism class the first
time we all started in class I was just
reading all these things and just going
wait a minute
every single thing because I was always
social but with crazy sensory processing
issues and a whole lot of like GI issues
and nobody could really explain what was
going on and it was kind of liberating
for me to get the eventual diagnosis I
didn't see it as a label and I think a
large part of why that was so empowering
for me
I was in a community of people where
neurodiversity is actually celebrated so
I think that actually placing a value on
that is probably more important than
it's not about getting a stable or not a
label it's how it's being accepted or
perceived and I've met many people at
MIT who are very social but in small
doses sometimes and they just have very
similar sensory issues and it's very
difficult I think just to describe
anybody as this is what we think is
neurotypical and this is what is not
neurotypical I think just accepting
everybody is probably the more we focus
on first principles the better we can
just be because it doesn't matter I
inject the short story on that before we
come to you I think I'm reminded of I
would have all my students over to my
house regularly and one year one of them
one of my brightest students who when we
all put in a person you'd most like to
have lunch with he put I don't like
people he came to my house my kids were
jumping all over him and he says I want
you to know this is my one social event
of the year I said well I hope it's a
good one you know yeah look like he was
having fun but at MIT we both the more
different you are the more you fit in
it's sort of the opposite of Harvard I
hear well I'll try to maintain there's a
good differences yeah so I'd like to
answer the question about what what I'm
excited about I think it relates to what
I'm the previous panelists mentioned and
I think I think we're we're in exciting
we're at an exciting point in the sort
of history and continued evolution and
human society in terms of the way we
deal with difference I think we're at an
important place there you know we have a
long history it you know with
we if you think about women's suffrage
to the civil rights movement where
groups who were different were
essentially the gay rights movement
groups who were who were different
different and just by virtue of their
difference we're persecuted were
oppressed were ostracized from society
and kept out of opportunities and in the
myriad of ways and I think I'm excited
about the time we are living in now
because I think for a for a long time in
this society it was a foregone
conclusion that someone who had autism
or someone who was neural atypical that
they were less intelligent that they
didn't really have anything that
contribute to society I mean up until
the late 1940s if you had any type of
cognitive difference you were you are
placed in the state institution so they
close the doors and for and you forgot
about families you know sign away their
family members because we're like no
they're different we don't we don't know
you know like you take them and and when
you and their there's their videos and
some of you may know Geraldo Rivera I
mean he's kind of infamous now but he
actually got came to fame through
exposing one of the with the largest
school in the country that that did this
and and when he and basically going in
there during an unscheduled visit and
and and shining a light on all the the
horrendous practices that were happening
there and I think and when he would talk
to some of the physicians and and staff
they would say we we don't even know
what these people are capable of we've
never tried we've never asked you never
tried we've never tried to teach them
and you think we don't know and and i
won't i won't speak about their
deplorable conditions because it upsets
me and that but i think if you're
interested you should you should should
do a Google search for willow
in Geraldo Rivera you know and you'll
see that video but Jose's a long gone
we'vewe've we recognize that there that
they have it that people who are
neurotypical have a have a unique
contribution and I feel like you know
where they we're not at the point yet
where narrow diversity or the movement
for neural diversity is seen alongside
the other movements I mentioned but it
but it is a civil rights issue and I but
I think we're close and I think and that
makes that makes me hopeful and excited
and and and obviously it's important to
me I have a personal stake in it but I'm
also because of my own personal
experience as a minority it means that
much more to me that I'm a part of this
fight and so so yeah that's what makes
you say ok what does it mean to be not
neurotypical I think that's a very
complicated question as um several other
people have said on the panel I think
that there are a lot of different ways
that people can be non neurotypical I do
think that there are people as Ned said
earlier that do kind of tend toward the
central tendency but there are a lot of
people in the tails of the Gaussian
distribution for example the most
notorious thing that is Gaussian like
has in a Gaussian distribution is
intellectual ability like somebody with
an intellectual disability is
neurodivergent but people on the right
side of the tail are also neurodivergent
for example if you are if you are so
intellectually advanced to the standard
school curriculum doesn't fit you then
yes you are neurodivergent you may not
fit in with your classmates you may not
you like you're in school you're bored
you hear them repeating things for 10
times like review time you like no see
that's an example of neuro divergence of
course autism and then even autism the
meaning of autism it's very much it's
multiple it it's not there's not just
one autism there's several flavors of
autism and for example like some people
may fit a more Asperger types and people
may
like some people some autistic people
may have an intellectual disability some
people may not have an intellectual
disability
some people may struggle more with
social skills and people may struggle
more with sensory stuff or executive
functioning in my case um I find
executive functioning difficulties that
is planning organizing etc more
difficult than social problems these
days my sensory issues while they
receded in the past I still find them
more disabling than my social issues so
yes even autism which is sort of seen
this monolithic thing autism for DCP
essays and like Oh does your child have
autism or the may institute ads that are
on the beti like does your child to
someone you love have autism they tend
to treat autism as the sort of
monolithic thing and it's not the same
goes with ADHD you know it could be
primarily primarily an attentive you can
be primarily hyperactive you can be a
mix of the two or you can have
Alzheimer's you can have some corpse
brain injury some sort of cognitive
disability there are so many different
ways to be neurodivergent also mental
psychiatric disabilities bipolar bipolar
or schizophrenia or borderline
personality disorder there are so many
different ways that you can be non
neurotypical and of course you're
dealing with all different kinds of
access needs because there is not one
single singular neurodivergent profile a
lot of people say those weirdos over
there but that's not how it is in order
to understand how we can make technology
more inclusive we have to understand how
multi-textured how multi-layered the
idea of neurodivergent neuro divergence
is even within a specific diagnosis you
can't just say hey you're autistic you
have these needs you have ADHD you have
these needs you have an intellectual
disability you have these needs for
example something that I mean I do agree
that there is such an AI there is such a
thing as universal design and I think
that there are ways to accomplish
Universal Design while taking an ik
taking
to account all these differences but in
order but you also have to be sometimes
it's important to have multiple settings
to accommodate different kinds of needs
for example my needs are different from
somebody who has dementia or an
intellectual disability I don't
necessarily need language simplified in
the same way that somebody with an ID
would but there are sometimes ways that
something designed for one population
can work for others for example there
was this is incredibly arcane but I
think that in this room it's probably
not a problem
there was this font designed by a
company called FS me it was designed for
this British British nonprofit that
works with people with intellectual
disabilities and it was designed for
adults with intellectual disabilities to
be easier to read but because of the
shapes of the letters because of the way
things are formed yeah and dissing it
disambiguates shapes like the capital i'
and the l and the lowercase a it's also
used for useful for people dyslexia and
then I don't even have either of those
disabilities and I find it and we're
readable so that's an example of how
Universal Design can take into account
all these very different kinds of
neurodivergent and make things
accessible you just beautifully answered
the next question thank you you're
you're like the innovator for where
we're going here I wanted to ask all of
you for for examples like that where
does you know designing for you no not
the majority actually wind up being
something that perhaps a lot more people
than you designed for really appreciate
and the font is a beautiful example
others thank you well so autism luckily
is non fatal so you have children with
autism which is what a lot of people
think of but then there are adults with
autism as joining us but one of the
issues is employment and employment is
probably the single most protective
thing against mental health negative
outcomes not any pill or any
therapy but having a job and people with
autism have about a 50% unemployment
rate people with autism and a college
degree have an 80% unemployment rate it
gets worse
competing for different jobs they're
well trained for something but there are
certain things that keep that raw brain
power locked in such as it's hard to
pass an interview because of the social
issues sometimes it's really significant
if 80% of what amounts to one or two
percent of your entire population ends
up unemployed so we took on this
challenge very carefully and developed a
jobs training program and a remote
digital job coaching platform and we
received a federal grant for this so we
have a congressional direct
congressional grant for digital job
training and what we realized we went
around okay what's important for someone
with autism to help get a job making eye
contact with the interviewer what else
is important trying to determine are you
talking too much are you not talking
enough okay how to determine the
appropriate language and level of
language and whether to use a swear word
or so forth in certain contexts okay how
to operate around that proverbial water
cooler all right so which of these
things is restricted only to autism and
not applicable to anyone else Yeah right
nothing right so we ended up generating
essentially a interview training program
useful for all useful for many and we
just got back yesterday we did a trip to
a college that wants to adopt our
program not only a technology for people
with the diagnosis but for people
generally seeking you know for college
and career readiness so this idea then
somewhat saying the opposite what I said
that you know if you take this seriously
that we are all on the spectrum well
that the flip side of that is tools well
tuned for people who sometimes have the
tougher version of the regular human
challenge of interacting with others if
you can get it there and nail it in a
copy in a really really complex
situation it may be broadly applicable
to all and that was an example yeah I
know can I just yeah add to that I think
and so and the other side of that
obviously is that when in when in
business decides not to hire someone
because they're not presenting
neurotypical characteristics it's a form
of discrimination right and so what we
do at the Institute is we host workshops
for businesses for entrepreneurs and we
say look this is the language of autism
this is this these you know if someone
is not making eye contact with you and
you and you think that that's
justification that that speaks to their
inability to to be a good employee or to
possess some skillset that you think is
valuable we're here to tell you that
you're wrong we're here to educate you
so that you don't continue to
discriminate people against people who
could potentially contribute and and
help your company grow and and
contribute to the creativity of design
and decision making and you know and all
in every aspect of the work that they're
doing and so so we you know we think
about that same issue and we we come up
with ways to train the you know come up
with tools for the the public the
general public in use to to empower them
to you know to sort of be the best
version of themselves and to be the you
know which is a inclusive environment
inclusive supportive nurturing
environment for everyone in the same way
it is for neurotypical people so I just
give some personal examples of stuff I
learned in the class which I started to
follow but I started deploying it on
coated coat neurotypical
people one of the things that I found
very useful is heavy blankets I don't
know how many people here I really sleep
very soundly when I put a heavy blanket
the deep touch pressure really helped me
and I got myself a rocking chair because
I felt like we couldn't back and forth
really coming and whenever some friends
of mine who get really stressed I just
used to get up and kind of just get them
to sit on the chair without actually
telling them to sit in the chair of
course like when you sit on a rocking
chair you start rocking and almost
immediately you can see that they can
start thinking a lot better so which
kind of tells me some of the things that
we've historically seen as a disability
or just on a pace a lot or they do some
of these they have some of these special
needs can actually be beneficial for a
whole group of people just with
different extent and I was talking
recently to neuro gastroenterologist at
MGH it was giving a talk here and he
said something like for the vast
majority of people who come into his
practice with something like irritable
bowel syndrome which nobody likes to
talk about he said in medicine because
couldn't quote only the people that are
not neurotypical exhibit these kinds of
things and he said the vast majority of
them are women and people on the autism
spectrum and he said that his practice
has evolved so much right now where they
actually don't think that a lot of the
problems people face is because of
either increased acid production or
inflammation in the gut it's something
to do with highly sensitive nerve
endings that kind of mediate strong
response from people and he said that as
soon as he realized that he decided he
cannot practice
only ghast ontology needs to investigate
noodle gastroenterology and it's helped
a lot of his other patients who are not
on the autism spectrum as well bringing
up a point we could have mentioned we we
have diverse neuronal systems in our
body too everybody keeps talking about
the brain and brain power but we have a
hundred million neurons and your gut
that exhibit REM like behavior when you
sleep and they learn and do all kinds of
cool things too so we we have a second
brain as Michael Gershon has written
about and others that also runs our
bodies as anybody who has teenage sons
like me and agree to as well her
stomachs I know we're getting near
dinnertime too dangerous topic any
further comments on yep I was just
thinking of two different things
number one the I'm thinking you
mentioned about gas GI issues reminded
me of two studies that I read one was
the intense world interpretation of
autism that I remember coming across a
few years ago and there's another one
like hyper bodies hyper minds where
people who are you know who tend to be
on the I'm far right side of the
intellectual distribution tend to have
stronger reactions to different
environmental factors and I remember I
think GI issues and allergies or one of
the things I came across so sometimes
people who experience the world more
intensely may also have physical
responses that are also more intense
based on these studies that I was
looking at fairly recently also
regarding sort of this universal design
theme that we were discussing I was also
thinking about how closed captioning and
subtitles are not only beneficial for
people who are hard of hearing or deaf
they're also helpful for the general
population at large
I remember hearing about this there's a
study yes I remember hearing about this
at a conference that I was at it was the
yeah it was a conference that the man
super comedian clusion was was putting
on a couple years ago and I'm one of the
researchers there was talking about
universal design and he had mentioned
that people of
people whether they're deaf or hard of
hearing or not we're able to benefit
from seeing subtitles on movies like for
example you know I know people who
aren't who aren't deaf or hard of
hearing that benefit from subtitling and
also there are folks like autistic
people and other people may have
auditory processing issues or attention
span issues that benefit from having
subtitles I've started turning them on
all the time I love them yeah you have
hearing that I did watch an old favorite
movie and you'll pick up a lot of things
you missed all right I want us to give
the audience time to ask questions and
there are microphones on both aisles so
please feel free to grab a mic and
anything goes here there's another
dimension assuming you have that
fictional neurotypical individual you
will navigate through time and the mind
will change and so a lot of I'm dealing
with an 86 year old mother who's had a
stroke but watching her try to use
technology like little things like a
carrot it means she should touch the
pointy part but she thinks that kind of
like a bracket so she touches the other
side and so there are a whole lot of
things or it's some designer who says
this looks cool and all meaning has been
stripped from the interface you have to
learn the arbitrary symbols and to be
blunt somebody who's 86 it's not likely
to rapidly adapt to a rapidly evolving
on user interfaces based on the whims of
some designer so there's a whole other
dimension to this which is just as we
navigate through time our minds will
change at me when I see your glasses I
just want the camera that tells me Who
am I looking at talking to name and I
lord knows what percentage of the
population would be desperate
I hear chuckles around so all of us
probably have something but I think a
real important aspect of this is no
change over time
within the population and that's a
really important thing for us to think
about because you know a 1-point when I
was here as an undergrad I had my first
hp-35 calculator and that was the state
of the art of digital technology and I
used to be the go-to guy now that I'm in
my 60s now it's like wait what is
snapchat and why are you doing it have a
real impact in terms of how we interact
with this stuff because people keep
arbitrarily changing interfaces for what
seems to be nothing more than a
commercial advantage I'll screw you up
and give you something else and force
you to learn it yeah thank you some
changes over time reveal what was
already always there so that gets harder
over time so you've got focused down on
the corner Arisa zand apply on that and
they can teach us what we should have
done all along to make something
intuitive and simple which sounds very
intuitive and very simple which it's
neither there's a company that is not
one that does lots of humanitarian stuff
for the world that pretty much makes
seven products with near slave labor and
has 100 billion dollars in the bank and
does nothing with it of great use for
the world and that unnamed Apple company
pretty much just makes things extremely
intuitive they put clothing on other
people's computers and I'm not biased at
all and but what's amazing is they got
that hundred billion dollars or whatever
because they made it intuitive it's
really really hard takes time to achieve
simplicity but it's so desperately
important there's more to it than it's
just hard because you have to make it
pixel perfect because what is intuitive
means it means that it will make sense
for me but we just agreed that there are
7 billion Me's out there and what's
intuitive in Abu Dhabi or Abidjan or you
know Akron and what's intuitive for the
86 year old for the six-year-old
how could we possibly make it intuitive
for everyone one lucky thing about this
great time where we live is new
technology is coming along that makes
that possible this is meta-level
technology we just had a wonderful
conference call with a different large
tech company today I can't reveal but
they're about to bring out to market
some amazing machine learning algorithms
these are the kinds that are iteratively
machine learning sort of machine
learning to the next degree and where
they want our use case because they want
a really hard problem where the software
would not only learn about itself and
get better at doing what it's going to
do but learn you and become better at
being the companion to you the cognitive
prosthetic the outsourced
brain of the the neural wiring that's
been pared away since since you were
younger in that case so it's an amazing
thing where we need to fight always to
achieve that simplicity and the
intuitiveness for all minds but also
there's some technology that might give
us a pass that can do its job to self
customized to people
you completely anticipated what I was
going to say Australian mom we the first
emotion that was not in the book that we
detected was frustration I was thank you
my name is Meryl Alper I'm a professor
at Northeastern so other side of the
river and I'm an ethnographer who
studies how kids on the autism spectrum
use media and technology I have two
questions the first one is you know
we're at MIT kind of home of epicenter
of Technology and wondering your
thoughts on the role of the social
science social sciences of social
scientists in kind of developing your
new technology and then the second
follow-up question because I think of
you know what can social scientists
bring is your thoughts on we're talking
about technology and the autism spectrum
and where you think talk of the
socio-economic spectrum fits into that
discussion as well okay I as the social
scientist on the panel I'll address
those issues my undergraduate degree is
in sociology and then so public policy
is basically social science so I do
think that sociological issues do come
into play I think that technology
reflect technology should or does
reflect the culture to which people
belong culture and society are embedded
in technology people often treat
technology is a sort of duress innate
'add entity that is not connected to the
culture of the designers and the culture
of the users but that's patently untrue
to give an example may sound a little
trivial but it's an example of how
culture is reflected in technology for
example things like spell checkers even
within one language one spell checker
won't work
for every language of English a
spellchecker made for the United States
will not work in any other country
because we can't spell but anyway also
things like facial recognition to use a
more serious example you need to be
aware that the machine needs to be able
to pick up people of different skin
colors and recognize that they're seeing
people there is actually this supposedly
intelligent hand washing
it's like hand dryer we're seeing it on
Twitter a little while ago and the there
was a white person that rubbed their
hands under it and it worked but
somebody I think it was either black or
Middle Eastern South Asian etc came up
and they tried it it didn't work so you
have to be aware of things like race or
gender you can't assume that your users
are of a certain gender you can't assume
that as people belong to a certain
social class you can't you can't assume
that people belong to this default as I
said earlier you have to be aware that
culture and identity and experiences are
related to technology they're not the
separate entities some people go like
here's social science and here's hard
science no we're people and because
we're people both these things intersect
and often quantitative research often
bears out the things that qualitative
research does anyway there's also you
know mixed methods research which I
really like
now regarding the issue of social
socioeconomic status of course a lot of
this technology that's used is expensive
like getting iPads a talk is expensive
getting glasses that help you interpret
the world is expensive and I do think
that it is absolutely imperative that
policymakers are able to fund these
services for people of all ages not just
children can use these technologies in
order to navigate the world more easily
in a way that helps them to adapt I
think that of course charitable
organizations could also do it I think
that the government is like the US
government has far more money than you
know any number of non
profits you know as much as a nonprofit
might want to donate also I also you
know the government is more efficient
they have more resources to distribute
these things they for example these
these services could be theoretically
covered on as telehealth there are a lot
of states that have clear but have
guidelines to tell for telehealth and
while some of them need to be reformed
to cover services beyond remote visits
or keeping data or other the other
technologies that are currently being
included in a lot of states telehealth
statutes I think that these tools these
adaptive tools can be included as
materials that can be covered by
Medicaid that that can be covered by
private insurance that could be covered
by vocational rehabilitation or other
state organizations like state-run
organizations that interface directly
with people with disabilities their
families and the people who support them
can i I think I feel very strongly about
this and I love mi key this is a very
homely community for me but I think we
have to be honest when we say that
sometimes there is a rush to actually
propose a technical solution for things
without really understanding the
ramifications of how they can be used
very concrete example for instance all
the bunch of risk assessment algorithms
that are coming out now which is really
like trying to evaluate a very
vulnerable socioeconomic ly
disadvantaged and historically
marginalized and even criminalized
audience group it seems to me like
several of the so-called like technical
solutions people are using let's use
machine learning algorithms to see whose
high risk medium risk or risk if it's
low risk let
just let them out let's stop being the
most incarcerated country in the
industrialized world and a lot of times
people don't really realize the way in
which it can exacerbate bias in the data
how actually something that was actually
designed with very good intentions by
the folks who created it can have really
harmful effects on the of marginalized
communities and I think the answer or a
way or approach to think about that is
it's it's it's sometimes very easy to
basically just be from the machine
learning community and say well the site
people are mostly doing soft stuff and
I'm doing probabilistic graphical models
or whatever and for me I think it was
very kind of a paradigm change where I
stopped seeing social science research
as any less rigorous than what I thought
I was doing and we need better ways to
kind of weave in qualitative methods and
actually understand the populations we
are working with before actually rushing
into design stuff interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary discussion is
absolutely required in order to make
this work I believe I agree agree on
socio economics gentleman who just left
there yet another commitment was he's
one of our clinical staff we have a
clinical staff because we run clinical
trials he's an MD psychiatrist but he
also had a grant for studying autism and
disadvantaged communities and so he's
done some esting studies and published
on that and it's informed our work just
very interesting you see that there's
certain communities with the black
community or even some further on the
fringe where it's like wow great they
have much less autism yeah no not
diagnosed harder to get the appointment
less of a point because the services
aren't there and so on and so forth
really some nuanced interesting stuff
but we've we've rolled that into what we
do had the privilege of a four-hour
dinner with Temple
Brendon and a lot of wonderful insights
so interesting that she can be in and
talk about so perfectly she's her own
rosetta stone but she gave some feedback
that like this is great but she prefers
things made of cardboard because it's
expensive and so when we recently
crowdfunded to get the device out into
community we took this into account and
created different methods for payment
plans and try to get hardware through
computer based services waivers and
health savings accounts and so forth
found ways to find other pockets of
money to pay for the hard part
literally the hardware and to give the
software very very very inexpensively
you have to think about what goes into
the lifecycle and the other pressures
that are going on and in people's lives
and we've tried to model that and
address it someday of course technology
costs come down that being said you know
I feel a little bit of pang of guilt
because we have to sell a piece of
hardware that's that's expensive along
with it but in the end we're much mostly
software and software has the magical
ability that you know someone in Myanmar
or in Maryland you know or someone whose
mother is ill and instantly download
something and if it's correctly
delivered and there is the platform you
can benefit in a billion people tomorrow
the software revision cycle and it can
be so fast and can affect so many people
so there's that capability to leapfrog
for people who are actually in the most
disadvantaged situations to suddenly
leapfrog
there are many next steps potentially of
development because of that come on to
Mystic I also just wanted to answer or
respond to that quickly I coming from
the world of education tech I feel like
there are a lot of great technological
tools that are create you know that are
born into existence by engineers and
like look what I've created this is
great thing and now what are we gonna
use it for well we use it for
and oh maybe teachers could use it to do
some some aspect of their job that
before was analog or manual you know
they think about all the applications
for this there's this thing this thing
at this piece of technology or this
invention and and if you if you know
anything about education tech there's
this like huge wasteland of companies
and products that have tried to permeate
or infiltrate the market and fail for
one reason another if you ask me someone
who comes from education I think it's
the social science piece that they miss
and I think that a lot of tech companies
are run by engineers and tech people
mathematicians quantitative people when
you know schools I mean they're the
industries that they they want to be
profitable and or succeed in are not
they're not you know mathematical
they're more like multicellular
organisms and it's messy and it's
qualitative and and there's background
in this context you know and if you you
want to boil it down to these neat
points okay this is our customer this is
this is the pain point this is what
we're gonna address right and we and
just roll it out to everyone chances are
you're gonna you're gonna feel because
you don't get the nuance and and I feel
like that's where social science really
comes into play and is really important
when you understand ER standing the
customer understanding the individual
tip Tip O'Neill a famous Massachusetts
politicians had a saying it was all
politics are local and I think I think
it's true of every aspect of our
experience it's all personal right and
so you have to understand everything
that goes into why the individual who
the integral individual is how they came
to be that way what motivates them and
and that's that that's the the
environment which they grow up the
family that raised them the experience
the educational experience all these
things the you know the social science
side you know there's socio economics
and so I think it's important it should
play much much larger role and the
conversations around how tech can be of
use and enough service to pop to
populations that that benefit from it
whether it's education and other
industries and so I think that
conversation doesn't happen as often
because it should all the next questions
getting up there I'll just remind of a
quote from the late Marvin Minsky who
would say you don't really understand a
problem until you've understood it in
many different ways and I've always
appreciated that as I try to bring in
the first few points in our work hi
everybody my name is Mabel Bern I'm
actually an undergraduate student from
UMass Boston and my question actually
comes something fin mentioned earlier
you told us a story about how when you
were young you had a physician tell you
that you would never learn or something
crazy like that which breaks my heart
because I'm an aspiring physician myself
and I feel like physicians should be an
ally to those that are neurodiverse I
know what advice would you give to like
patient care providers to be more of a
neuro inclusive as you would say I would
say that firstly everyone can learn
whether they have an intellectual
disability or not everybody has an
innate intelligence everybody has the
ability to understand the world to at
least some extent also I would say that
while you should understand that people
have a disability and may have
limitations but doesn't necessarily mean
that they can't grow sort of that whole
growth mindset mentality suppose the
fixed mindset and understanding that
your job is to support you're not
supposed to bring down these
pronouncements because you know as I
said like you know this doctor thought
that I would never learned that I had an
intellectual disability and then a
couple years later they saw me doing
other things and then I got put into
then I was labeled gifted like a couple
years later so you know it's like he
thought I was here and then I turned out
to be here so you have to be you can't
just go this
how you're gonna be forever you can't
think that way and it's just you cannot
put you can't I just like bring down
these absolute pronouncements you have
to grow with the person you can't just
like sort of assign them into a role and
expect them to fit into that role for
the rest of their lives it's just not
it's not productive it's demeaning it's
dehumanizing it's demoralizing its
destructive and also it's just dead
wrong
hi I'm bill Fleming I'm a business and
marketing guy and I work with the local
design community and my best friend has
a five year old who's nonverbal autistic
and she introduced me to the concept of
narrow diversity and unfortunately she
couldn't be here but I'm big - and this
is amazing topic one of the things that
I'm aware of given that part of this is
a design symposium is that a big part of
successful design is prototyping user
research iteration and because we're
talking about 'men of your expressions
was people on the margins makes it
difficult for users of research just
looking to get some feedback on your
take on that whole aspect of it sorry
the question so it was how do you find
the people who are gonna give you the
feedback if they're the ones that are
harder to find or it might be to park
where someone is how do you find that
because the diversity within those
margins is wide six year old and it
could be all different factors with that
and then once you do get people how do
you actually go about testing given some
feedback tip mechanisms that traditional
designers would get are challenged
because of different communication
issues for sure taken quickly there I
mean there are actually federal
guidelines on what usability looks like
and what how to test to some degree not
perfect but there are some starts and
there some great
companies and and others who've
attempted so you can follow their lead
but for sure I think what you're hinting
out there is it's hard to hear what
literally people don't say if they're
non-speaking autistic sand to hear the
feedback you also need to be able to
incorporate so I want to design a
syllabus I want to design a product I
want to design a communication a blog
post and reach a lot of people how do I
go through that iterative process and
incorporate the feedback if it's gonna
come to a mind that wasn't expecting
that answer how do I really know what
that answer meant and again diverse team
respecting members of teams opinions as
equal to one's own eatery and test you
said science right you set a hypothesis
you set a threshold and go out there and
test it and then respect the rubric
don't say okay well I think if 80% of
people who come in with a diagnosis
according to the a das can use it then
it's the thing let's do it and then they
come in and it's only 70% you're like
yeah but I think I'd be fine no have a
rubric respect it otherwise you're
iterating the rubric which you've also
can do but take it very very seriously
people I find who are in a community a
marginalized community a different
community are extremely if approached
correctly extremely eager to help out
they want to help others parents of
people with different abilities are very
eager to help other parents you know
someone who's five years into the
diagnosis sees someone who's one year
into the diagnosis I mean diagnosis of
their children and says I know what what
you're going through here you think
there's a quick fix there isn't and the
depression comes next year but I can get
you through that because I know what the
light is like on the other end of the
tunnel and people really want to help if
you listen to their voices
add something to that to those of you do
machine learning know you have a
training set and it's almost never big
enough so you jitter the content a
little bit to try to get more out of it
and similarly when you don't have quite
as many users coming in or what tends to
happen I've seen like Microsoft years
ago it was very cool to get paid 50
bucks an hour and go in their modern
facility and see the new coolest thing
and one of the new coolest things that
got two thumbs up from everybody was
this little animated paper clip it
looked really happy to see you and and
looks really happy to give you advice
and if you're in a really great mood I'm
testing some cool new stuff and you're
really happy that's that's a great
experience so no surprise that got to
thumbs up under that circumstance right
what happened later was it would pop up
when people were frustrated and things
aren't working and you know you've got
this major deadline and this little
thing is walking into your office and
smiling and and looking happy and you're
ready to shoot it right because they
didn't they didn't jiggle the data right
they sort of treated everybody in that
state that they came in so I think again
we can get even greater diversity out of
our test users by having them take it
home or test it in different
circumstances or you got to be careful
how you do this because you don't really
want to upset people but maybe put them
in a situation that's a bit more
stressful not just this happy treat them
well I mean you do want to treat people
well so it's delicate but I think
together we come up with ways that
stimulate more of the real life
situation real life uses the very best
for testing let them take it home and
then they get past their friendly oh I
like it everything's good and then they
start telling you what's really broken
and miserable about this yep
University there D school called design
thinking so some of you may be familiar
with this um or not but a big part of
that is but design thinker and a big
part of that is asking why so when you
see that paper clip it's not like oh
that's cute
why what do you like about it what so to
understand why will help inform what to
do with it yeah I'm thinking in some of
the methodology so that might be
interesting to some people yep under
what circumstances interesting story
about the paperclip do you know where
the paperclip ended up well he's living
in Oahu with his life partner jar jar
binks bill gates got a standing ovation
when he said it was going away I'm Jill
I'm a grad student with the integrated
design management program here and I was
just and were doing research right now
for kids with special needs and a lot of
stigma comes when especially when
they're in school I guess in your
experience especially in the education
side is there any way for us I how can
we make schools more neurodiverse in the
sense you know are there any quick wins
because not everybody can afford
technology I'm not just besides
technology can I'm we're looking at the
systems are there certain products or
maybe implemented that actually do
create significant impact I was thinking
of something similar to what I said
earlier about the medical profession you
you have to understand that every
student is an individual and that they
all have the capability to grow if you
don't want to come in with these
assumptions that just because a student
has a disability that they have a
problem and that it's important to
recognize that the standard curriculum
may not necessarily be appropriate for
the student in question because you know
it might be too linear it might not be
linear enough it might be too hard it
might be too easy it might be too
repetitive it might not be repetitive
enough there are all these different
variables that that that are important
to take into account now I know that
there are standards to what you have to
adhere given that there's the Common
Core and various state standardized
tests the SAT the eight there are all
these
standardized tests high-stakes testing
that you have to take into account but
there are ways in which you can still
differentiate instruction especially for
students who qualify for services under
the idea the individuals with
Disabilities Education Act so you just
kind of have to build diversity and
build inclusion from the ground up as
opposed to going oh here are early you
know the 80% of the students that match
this central tendency they're in like
the hump of the bell curve and you've
got these folks on the tails and we're
just gonna like kind of staple on these
accommodations afterwards no you have to
build it in from the ground up and
recognize that you're gonna have
outliers no matter what happens there
were always exceptions and oh basically
you have to apply exception handling to
education there's gonna be exceptions
and I'm not saying that students with
disabilities are errors but you have to
handle these situations as they come up
as opposed to saying you know what if
you don't fit into this this thing this
hump of the curve you don't matter or
you are inconvenience or you know as a
certain government official said that
students disabilities were the single
most irritating problem for teachers in
the country
no that's obviously not right so I would
also add I think you're also referring
to the phenomenon in schools where
children are discriminatory towards
other children right and that plays out
I mean and I as a former Boston Public
School teacher I taught with special
needs and in Charlestown and and you
you've recognized right away that
they're hyper sensitive to any kind of
difference that they observe and their
response is usually negative it's
usually to shame a person or to make
foot you know like ah look at this
person there you know and it could be
the smallest thing like I would if I
came to class with my hair down as
opposed to being up in the but the class
was like erupt like oh my god
hey miss mrs. a you know you know like
they call me miss mr. a because they
couldn't pronounce my last name but but
you know something as subtle as that I
think so one of the things we have to so
that told me as a teacher that one it's
you know obviously it's part cultural
but it's probably also natural right for
us to notice these notice differences in
others right and maybe it comes from
like we have to determine very quickly
whether or not this person is a threat
you know and it's so like can is a
friend or fall I need to know right away
right but so but I think what we what
teachers have to do and I think schools
are the best places to do it is is to
cultivate a truly inclusive environment
right and and there's there are models
for what that looks like and there if
you go to the Hendon Henderson school in
Dorchester you'll see full inclusion at
its best and the whole point of
inclusion was so that students who were
typical and atypical could see each
other learn from each other normalize
difference and and celebrate but and
celebrate it and accept it and embrace
it but it's not enough just to have
children of different types and learning
styles in the same room you the teacher
has to be very skilled at facilitating
inclusion facilitating celebrating like
one of the things I was always
intentional about doing is uh is
celebrating all kinds of examples of
success you know and making sure that
everyone was celebrated for something
that was unique about them and so to
combat the negative the negative culture
of shaming and but I think so that we
need to we need to be more consistent
about that across schools but also
culturally because they learn it they
learn it from somewhere I think teachers
have to take I have to become more
skilled and and more assertive about
cultivating a learning or in an
environment that is inclusive that
celebrates difference
and then and then grow from there I'm
carsick and yeah I completely agree with
what was descent
I would have a colleague who studies the
manifestation of chronic diseases after
one crosses well into adulthood like
post 30 40 years old and some of the
findings that are coming in right now is
that when you are told that repeatedly
that you are different and you basically
have a very hard time in school it turns
out that the way that physiologically
processed by the body the adverse impact
sometimes are not known until a very
long time and it somehow the body just
seems to skip a score of what happened
and some of the studies that are
basically drawing parallels with you
know soldiers who come back from wars
with PTSD they begin to associate
memories of very crazy things that
happened with them when a bomb exploded
or a colleague died that is very
triggering for them and sends their body
into a tailspin this researcher was
saying over and over again when she was
tracking these people all the way back
to their childhood adverse events during
childhood and repeated social adverse
events in school is extremely damaging
and something that I think everybody
should just take very seriously because
it tends to be very internalized and
physiologically processed I think oh
you're great yes okay should go back to
me I have a just a comment related to
the current question a lot depends on
how an accommodation is offered my son
has sensory needs and when he was told
like whoa you have a particular need so
we can bring in a bumpy cushion for your
chair or a strap so you can bang your
feet on it it helped but he hated it
because he was the only kid in the room
who had a different chair and then the
next year he went into a classroom where
the teacher said we have a lot of
different chairs which one would you
like to all the kids and he had such a
better year so just starting from the
place that we're a community where
people need different chairs example
example we were pointing out our class
filling out this matrix of nerd diverse
characteristics and so many people with
no labels shared exactly the same I bet
a lot of kids loved having those other
options right so let's offer those
things to everybody that's great yes
thank you my name is Vanessa I'm a
postdoc at MIT and my question goes to
both Rafi Gannett I suppose earlier
today we had the MIT intelligence quest
campaign starting and Eric Schmidt was
there and he spoke about that the future
of I suppose everything is in in the
intersection of AI and healthcare now I
suppose somehow you fit into that
category so congratulations on that but
he also mentioned that he feels that
regulation is something that should come
basically as late as possible
therefore my question to you would be
how and in which ways really do you
cooperate with regulators in the
specific industry that you're working
with to ensure that the products you
develop are actually for the benefit of
the people who need them
thank you important question an
important time where we are the human
brain is graduating the human brain is
now capable of making things that can
have brain like intelligence and then
can go back and help amplify fix augment
the brains of the rest of us it's it's
an amazing time it can be used for ill
it can be used for good so they're
regulators who make sure that something
is medically safe there are not
regulators necessarily at another
level although there are policy people
who will help us think about whether
something is morally safe and I think
each is important one good point of
reassurance many people worry about
artificial intelligence taking us back
over and giving us any of these movies
that we've all created through time when
there's a dystopian future we've made
those through time and they were also
Greek plays we will be fine
we self-regulate we will not probably
create an intelligence that swallows us
back up it's possible the singularity
probably not I said what regulators now
and in the very very clear sense are
extraordinarily important partly because
of some of the things we mentioned these
families are under tremendous stress the
members of the family who have the would
be label and the other members of the
family and there is a desperation index
that you can plot and it's extraordinary
normally a product will be of utility as
measured by will Peter will whether
people will procure it based on the
certainty to which you believe that it
will cause benefit and some kind of cost
and that curve could be linear curve for
parents of say autism so I know is
extraordinary it's if there's even more
than zero chance that it might work
you're gonna try it within whatever
means you have and that hump to the
curve is the desperation index and I
think it's very important to regulate to
make sure people don't take advantage of
those families and to not take advantage
and to market correctly and to have
backing and underpinnings to what you do
is a large part of what for instance FDA
does for regulation it's not necessarily
what we might think a whole bunch of
clinical studies and it's just about
what those 0.99 or 0.999 it's also do
you have good manufacturing practices so
each time you turn it out it'll be
identical do you report when people
complain and many other aspects so
regulation is very very important
that being said the philosophy
regulation can be self policed by a
community and the some regulations have
slowed things down so I think there's
this tension between what person said
earlier and I was at the event and where
I think digital medicine needs to go so
we take on board good manufacturing
practices that are the underpinnings of
an FDA process so cooperating with and
taking the digital guidance there was
new digital guidance released as
recently as my birthday December 15th so
a few months ago on what digital
medicine can mean and we're cooperating
by virtue of following those guidelines
and so the whole world the whole country
the the regulatory bodies are learning
what it means to create a product that
can cause benefit can be a therapeutic
and yet it isn't a drug or surgery or
laser or something like that it's a
behavioral process instrumental aided by
software so this is that amazing time
the brain is circling back on itself and
our behavior which we always have known
as an indication of whether someone is
on one side or another of that curve now
that behavior can be used as medicine to
affect the change in the brain that's
that's needed I couldn't have said it
any better I think also sometimes
there's a tendency to just make
technology the villain and certainly
regulation is important but it kind of
makes me think about the Monopoly board
game the precursor to the Monopoly board
game was actually creator wanted to
alert people about the ravages of
capitalism and the dangers of greedy
landlords but the way it was popularized
is the rules and everything was
same just now it was your job to be the
landlord and it just by changing the
first principle goal the whole dynamic
of the game changed and so sometimes
when we think of regulation it's not
machine learning sport it's basically
it's not a human being
for example the use of any technology
say for a vulnerable population the
question is why aren't we using some of
you know the causal inference stuff that
Roz works on right now to actually find
out instead of just predicting who's
high risk low risk or medium risk why
don't we actually understand if you take
away a driving licence from somebody
who's just been arrested and you expect
them to come and have court hearings
where failure to appear in court is
another cross mark against your record
and that's what the algorithms
predicting the causal route is something
else
and technology can actually be very
powerful in identifying those problems
several times I think the fundamental
question becomes what is it that we
actually value and so all the good
things that can come from technology
that can be prevented by increased
regulation I think the larger question
is what is what do we actually value and
can we actually get agreement that is
what I would say you're just making me
think of the interesting case where you
know if you saw like a lot of kids with
behavior problems in school they found
if they fixed their sleep half the
attention and behavior problems went
away right so with a lot of the
technology these days you can see if a
person sleeping well or not you might go
back and say maybe he wasn't just
misbehaving behind the wheel of the car
maybe he was he's sleeping bad and maybe
he's sleeping bag because he's in some
housing with really bad noise and bad
conditions and if we fix some of that
maybe some of these other problems would
drop dramatically so technology can help
us get to the causal factors to Chrissie
hi um so we're talking about how we can
design technology to help people with
autism but technology is not always the
answer and so that's what I was
wondering if you could touch on how
technology or the use of it can also in
some sense be like disabling or be a
negative thing challenging question is
of course there are you know anything
like technology like any other tool that
we use can be used either for good or
for ill for example if like some people
some autistic folks may get so sucked
into using let's say a computer as a
communication tool they get so I think
it's so stuck I think it's so sucked
into it that it's harder for them to
focus on other things or they get
distracted by games on their phone there
are plenty of different reasons why
there may be some issue that causes
technology to be detrimental or the
autistic person question just may not
like using technological methods to
solve their problems I mean some folks
just like regardless of age just don't
necessarily feel that that's the
solution for them so I do think that I
don't think that technology or anything
else isn't unalloyed good there are
there detriments and positive we take
this extremely seriously and so thank
you for the question and someone goes
back to ask this question about
regulatory so regulation and it's all
about risk analysis so what are the what
are the possible risks so for instance I
have autism
I wear this and everyone knows I have
autism so is that a risk comes back to
identity and and how challenging is that
these days but it's not just these days
it's these days and one school we're
working with in Plymouth another school
in Lawrence Lawrence is a very different
community than Plymouth if you don't
know you know probably the stigma could
be greater in Lawrence so what is the
stigma value of wearing this and then it
comes to how it's messaged which I think
was said from this part of the room so
is this something like hey everyone
tomorrow your friend and classmate is
gonna get something really cool and I
know you're all gonna want to try it but
you can't until next week and it's like
oh it's the cool thing that's coming
he's getting this thing from Google for
well he kind of has these differences
and we're gonna help him everyone be
okay and be polite so messaging really
matters but so we tested that will there
be stigma so we brought people in the
experts children with autism who know
what school is like and you know when
things go catastrophic ly wrong in a
social environment in school and asked
try this would you wear this etc so
that's paper we published data on their
perceptions their parents perceptions
and later another paper we brought it to
the school asked the child with the
children with autism as well as the
classmates and the teacher and the para
and the parent how did it go was this
better than you expected what were the
problems what were the issues and we
capture that and we just went to that
school yesterday some of the teachers
expressed well I don't know with this
out people and could this be an issue
and by the way you know what's deal with
Google glass you know listen this is
actually the next version of Google
glass that people don't necessarily know
came out but you know isn't that passe
what's the deal okay so we went talk to
one of the students who was actually a
programmer doing some VR and hey we
tried glass no I never have would you
like to yes I mean like throws down the
thing that he was doing come on over and
so we assess these risks but there are
very real risks around I mean simple
possible risk you know you could fall or
something like that but also these very
important ones about social risks
technology can assume it's always going
to be good and it absolutely won't be
and that comes back to the iterative
design unless you intentionally think
about what are your riskiest assumptions
and test them yeah always test to add to
that at one aspect of brain power
software it you know so it's essentially
a game five social interaction and one
one tension that Matt and I have had is
as a as someone who grew up a gamer you
know I'm like oh like we should make
your avatar like we should let people
choose and you could grow as you get as
you get more skilled they should get
muscles and they you could have get
change the outfits he was like no no no
no we don't want to make the game too
good that way they don't write it's not
actually about the game it's not
actually about the technology it's about
facilitating this human connection right
this human interaction right
I was like wait what we don't wanna make
the game good but I think to you know to
the extent that I would have won that
argument and made this great game I
think it would have made ultimately made
the software and technology less
effective because it would have been a
deterrent to to genuine social
interaction which is what we actually
want to encourage in trains oh the mic
my colleagues am like vertically
challenged angle this to my my name is
Fatih I work at Boston Children's Museum
I do a lot of accessibility or an
inclusion in the museum my question
actually sort of half got answered by
your comment about nesting in the
product so it might be this my end up
being more like a piggyback comment I'm
rather than question but I just had a
thought
about social emotional aspects over the
technology or accommodation in general
so I worked with this company that makes
robots for kids with autism and it has a
lot of good functions about how they
sort of like pitch their product on one
of the ways that they did it was that
because it's like so cool and it's like
you know human like a cute human-like
looking that like if this kid has it
like other kids got interested in like
what the child has and then like he
helps open up the conversation because
often time these kids have some issues
maybe with like a social interaction
sometimes that's sort of how they
presented us like this is a cool thing
that the child can have and that helps
other kids to be more interested in this
child and then that can sort of help
with the social interaction
and I hear sort of a similar comment or
similar arguments about like some like a
service animals that sometimes kids with
autism have or companion animals and
again that sort of like helps open up
the conversation so that's like a really
so it's you know it can be presented as
like a really positive thing but how
someone else I'm sorry I didn't catch
your name
about how she was explaining about the
bumpy chairs and how having something
different can make you stand out in a
wrong way is a sort of polar opposite
side of the issue like I just don't know
like what exactly makes the difference
of like I have this like something like
really cool and special and like people
are interested in me because of this
versus I feel stigmatized because I have
this show product as you can see I have
visual impairment and I think a lot of
times what I hear I mean what I heard
growing up but I think I still hear it
now it's a lot of blind kids often
especially for their mainstream um have
struggle using assistive technology not
because they can't use it but because
they are afraid of standing out in a
wrong way unfortunately I think my
personally they help to really totally
not care about this heard of like helped
me like kind of like excel in school but
um I was raised mainstream siding I go
to like a specialized applying school or
anything about how the blind school
teacher that I was getting some support
from how she was sort of telling me is
that I gained like I'm sort of like
again know she was telling me that I was
kind of like a success example while
it's really difficult for her to
encourage other kids to use whatever a
device that she was introducing because
again like the other key is like we
don't necessarily want to stand out in
that time like I was like 10 and she was
like asking me like why I don't I feel
okay you think it's all like I don't
know but but again I think my question
is or comment it's like what what's
making a difference between something
that
like really cool because you have it
versus like I just feel really
embarrassed because I'm using this I'm
standing out in the wrong way um part of
my thinking last day especially again
this argument comes from like either
like a robot type of product or animal
like it's something that like seems like
a companion rather than a tool I don't
know again I don't have any answer to
myself but I don't know that if that's
somehow helping more with the social
emotional piece
oh how especially kids you know can use
these technology and I don't know if you
again I need you to answer some of the
questions by testing but I don't know if
you have other thoughts about again like
when you make your product or design
something how that sort of can be a cool
thing or can be more like a normalizing
thing that everyone can use thanks for
comment before we addressed that I just
want to be mindful of time because we're
gonna try to have everybody on to their
next things by 8:00 so I'm gonna ask you
to not only respond to her comment but
make your closing statement of anything
else you you want to say as as well and
then we'll adjourn and then people can
have informal additional Q&A if they
want but I wanted to respond to a
question and I think for me it relates
to the question that the woman I think
Jill was a day who asked about inclusion
and in addressing stigma neck and a
traditional educational environment and
I do think that it is it's about the
culture right I think it's about what
culture is is being fostered in that
particular environment that ultimately
dictate how our products or technology
or this thing that could cause you to
stand out will be perceived right I
think when you and a healthy productive
learning Orion environment that is
inclusive and celebrates difference
they're they're they're you remove the
antagonism
of negative you know attention right so
so why wouldn't you then want to have
something that can can support you and
help you right I think only only in
environments that are the harmful Lord
or Thor where there's where there's
caught with real cause for fear right
where there was a real threat of harm
mental harm physical harm or you know or
just ostracism then does that you know
sort of a version arise there's like I
don't want to stand out it's not I know
I have this experience I thought it's
uncomfortable I want to avoid it you
know but it's about the it's about the
environments about the the culture that
that is shared within that environment I
think we've been fortunate so far to to
introduce our products and environments
that are supportive and celebrate the
first difference and things like that
but but I would say it's less than has
less to do with the product itself and
more the environment I think that I
agree that it's absolutely important to
avoid stigma when introducing
accommodations or technology or other
assistive tools that help students with
disabilities and that can be
accomplished a number of ways for
example you several people actually
mentioned like introducing it as a cool
thing is something interesting that
other students can enjoy or offering the
same offering the same tool or
technology to other students to sort of
diffuse the stigma a third option
however is to present this thing as 2d
stigmatize disability itself people
often treat disability as though it were
a bad word that should be avoided I
don't think it should be avoided we as
humans exist with different abilities
and different disabilities and I think
that it is absolutely important not to
shy away
from recognizing that disability is
something that affects people and it can
affect and it's one of the few one of
the few disadvantaged or marginalized
groups that anybody can join at anytime
anybody can get in an accident you know
anybody can you know have a brain injury
get dementia get Alzheimer's get some
sort of condition that affects the brain
affects cognition affects intelligence
so it's important to not only practice
Universal Design but work on the
structural factors that create stigma
around disability in the first place so
that if if a stoop that there's like a
reason why a given student is the only
one that uses that tool that that
student isn't stigmatized that they
aren't me to stand out just for being
who they are and having a disability you
have to be honest you have to recognize
that it is not something that you can
avoid it's not something that can be
sort of euphemized and pushed away
disability is not bad word and neuro
diversity is the default state of the
human condition we are all we are all
different and that isn't a bad thing we
need to incorporate that into our very
lives and within our philosophies of how
to create technology that assists people
with disabilities disability again is
not a bad word I think to conclude I'll
I'll basically just recap my own
experience which is very very empowering
for me when I first took crosses class
they had it had all these readings as
assignments and you had to write answers
to some questions that were posed after
you read them and usually I think my
assignments I turned it like 20 or 21
pages for every question the other
instructor actually stopped me saying
can you please stop doing that because I
actually have to wake up early just to
grade
and usually riddled with grammatical
errors and all kinds of stuff but I
still remember when I got the feedback
from Roz she used to correct all the
grammatical mistakes in my assignment
and it was just filled with very
thoughtful responses as well as oh my
god this is such such a cool insight and
I never actually seen a professor who
was that welcoming of insights from a
student and finally when I got the
diagnosis and I went to Roz
she said something like of course you
are on the spectrum how else do you
think you got into MIT I think she and
she kind of supplemented that by saying
not to worry it's more of a requirement
if you are a faculty member and so ever
since that happened I kind of learned to
just enjoy myself without being too
judgmental it was a gradual process and
we have these events at the Media Lab
called members week where a lot of human
beings just come to this place for two
whole days and after one of the meetings
we I was just telling Roz it's just been
too many human beings the last couple of
days I just want to be by myself and she
said well I'm you know I'm very similar
and so we kind of were high-fiving and
nobody else could understand like why we
were doing that which was cool and also
in cases where I've had to go and
present make a presentation or speak
with people she's also importantly
pushed me out of my own comfort zone a
little bit because sometimes I feel like
in order to function just as it's
important to celebrate neurodiversity
you have to stretch yourself just a
little bit just out of your comfort zone
and that's happened many times and I
just think that that kind of an
environment can be very very powerful
more than any single technology or
design that environment was
very impactful for me and I would say
that I wish that every person who feels
that he or she is neuro typically
divergent if any such thing exists
deserves to be in that kind of an
environment
Thanks well first I want to address the
last question and then do tiny summary
so last question I didn't implode your
name yes suckie suckie well thank you
and so you you posed the question I
believe what can help someone with the
need adopt adopt the technology that can
help serve that need but and not want to
reject it and what it could label the
person as and I don't have a perfect
answer but I believe in micro successes
so micro success is built into
everything we do very very small and
achievable goals that keep giving the
feedback of you've achieved and that can
have a spreading capability a spreading
effect on confidence and it strikes me
that you particularly are someone who's
very confident and since you were
describing something happen to you at
age 10 you you know that came early for
you and that's that's fabulous and
that's been a coping strategy and a
protective layer around you some people
begin with very little confidence and
have the lack of confidence reinforced
so how do we enforce an increase in
confidence and one answer is this micro
successes idea it's not the only another
thing to remember is that a child's
brain is still learning it's still
forming and that comes on both sides so
you can introduce that forming brain to
something in a new way you can color it
you can say this is cool and you can
trick someone into believing something
is cool and it becomes cool likewise who
are those other kids in the class who
are the bullies they're just kids
struggling to find their identity and
you find your identity by defining it
against someone else sometimes
or finding this little part in which
you're safe you can carve that out by
decrying what others have that makes
them different cuz deep down inside you
know that you're different and so but we
can teach them and I was there in a
classroom where the mother of one of the
kids that we have worked with gave a
lesson to the class she's a special
needs teacher and she asked everyone so
who here goes to bed with the lights
still on who goes to bed with the lights
off who rushes your teeth like this who
brushes your teeth like that who likes
sweet things who likes cold things and
everyone was just all over the map it
was that that randomly distributed
matrix that you were showing me earlier
and just like okay so you're all
different and why don't you guys who our
lights on go over there and lights off
go over there and you know can you find
ways that you could make fun of each
other of course you can you all are
different and you know it's so simple
and trite but it's not this is a
learning brain who's saying oh wow I
have something about me that's a little
peculiar particular you dissing kradic
beautiful something I can embrace that's
me that's identity these are all flip
sides of the same thing and she rendered
that beautiful lesson out there and then
it was like okay who here has you know
has a has you know something has a name
and a label okay there's that well you
know how different is that kind of
difference than the differences that you
already realized that you are you have
and I thought that was a beautiful
lesson and a simple way of addressing
and of your question from earlier how to
introduce it just one of thousands of
possible ways but to train the learning
brain and so I'd say if anything and
wrapping up lets you closely to the
brain it's this amazing possibly most
complicated little Wiggly piece of
matter in the universe although we're
biased and try to understand it us and
bring solutions that actually have some
thing to some basis in the brain and
let's do science so science is testing
hypotheses so that comes down to
hypothesis riskiest assumption
of the person I'm trying to serve will
actually benefit from this will adopt it
will like it that's science that's
testing that's being humble and we have
the privilege here of being under the
tutelage of Professor Picard all of us
who is carefully methodically done
science for decades when there was no
such thing as effective anything
effective computing effective science
and has created this field not because
necessarily just of good words or good
ideas but of good science and I think we
all need to remember that humbling
lesson of testing our assumptions and
building confidence in ourselves and
what we're doing and in each other all
right I wasn't expecting all these nice
comments but I just would like to ask
all of you to join me in thanking our
panelists who I have had a family
[Applause]
you